To try to understand the relationship between edges and nodes in a planar graph
we're going to use a result due to Euler--same Euler as before.
To do that we're going to need another concept about planar graphs.
Here's a planar graph on five nodes.
Again, we have a notion of nodes. We have a notion of edges.
We're also going to now talk about a notion of regions in a planar graph.
Regions are kind of areas that are boxed off in the graph,
plus the region outside of the graph.
Turns out that's a really useful thing to be able to talk about.
This particular graph has three regions.
We'll right it's got 5 nodes, 6 edges, and 3 regions.
Now, our good friend Euler discovered a fascinating relationship between these values.
For any planar graph, n - m + or is equal to 2. Really?
Does that work in this case?
Let's check this formula with the values for this particular graph.
We've got n - m, 5 -6 is -1, plus 3 is indeed 2. Interesting.
We're going to figure out why that is in just a moment,
but let's let you practice first understanding what these regions are.